et celle qui sera au sens de ce
téléguidage c'est une québécoise une
ingénieur aérospatial de la nasa
farah ali b que je retrouve à pasadena
californie bonsoir madame à libé alors
vraiment c'est un honneur de vous parler
parce que vous allez faire des choses
extraordinaires au cours des prochains
jours
d'abord ce persévérance c'est astro
mobile va arriver demain est-ce que
comment ça arrive sur marseille êtes
vous inquiète de la façon dont il va se
poser c'est ce que je suis un peu
nerveuse donc ça fait déjà sept mois
qu'on voyage vers mars le lancement
était à la fin juillet 2020 mais là
c'est vraiment on est dans les dernières
heures est en fait les dernières sept
minutes sont les 7 minutes et plus
stressante du voyage c'est le temps que
ça prend du moment qu'on rentre dans
l'atmosphère de mars jusqu'à pâques on a
péri sur la surface de mars
et ça c'est stressant c'est compliqué
parce que tout est automatisé il faut
que tout en est exactement comme
planifié pour qu'on atterrisse pour
qu'on atterrisse bien on coran dans
l'atmosphère certains dansent déploie
parachute et après on utilise un jetpack
pour m
et quand vous dites on téléguident comme
c'est très loin marche
j'imagine que vous pouvez pas en temps
réel
téléguidé parce que vos commandes
prendre combien de temps pour se rendre
d'abord en ce moment ça prend environ 12
minutes pour qu'une commande qui va de
la terre 20 mars à la vitesse de la
lumière
donc c'est ça comme vous l'avez dit une
fois qu'on est sur mars c'est pas comme
un joystick ou une voiture téléguidée le
conte et la aux commandes on prépare ce
total avance donc à chaque nuit
martienne on prépare un plan pour le
robot on lui envoie ça le matin robot
fait toutes ces activités pendant la
journée et chaque soir ils nous envoient
des données des photos qui nous permet
de planifier la prochaine journée
donc ça vaut votre vos commandes partent
à la vitesse de la lumière
et c'est à quelle distance vous avez dit
ça dépend parce que marche tourne autour
du soleil comme la terre mais un axe
plus long parce que plus éloignée du
soleil une année martienne c'est quoi
ces 650 jours à peu près ça c'est
presque deux ans terrestres bon et donc
la distance de la terre à marc changent
constamment
c'est exactement à d'autres comme la
distance change le temps que tu apprends
pour nos commandes de 30 20 mars change
aussi donc il ya des saisons où on s'est
juste 7 8 minutes et là on va tirer
savez 12 minutes et en fait ça va
s'empirer dans quelques mois ça va être
presque 18 minutes que ça va prendre
pour se rendre vers mars
il ya même une intense spécial oumar se
retrouve de l'autre côté du soleil de la
terre
donc on peut même envoyer dont de radio
pendant ce temps on a donc une période
d'à peu près 1 voir qui va se passer au
mois de septembre où je prends des
vacances parce qu'on peut dire au bon ok
on peut parler d'accord la mission de ce
robot parce qu'on a déjà envoyé une
curiosité en 2012 je crois on a déjà
envoyé des engins téléguidés sûrement
quelle est la mission de persévérance à
ce que c'est vraiment la mission
principale de trouver s'il ya eu vie sur
mars oui ou non
oui c'est ça c'est la première mission
qui va faire de l'astrobiologie sur une
autre planète et ce qu'on veut savoir
c'est s'il ya eu peut-être de la vis aux
marques
il ya des millions d'années dans ce
temps là il ya à peu près de deux
millions d'années la terre ressemble la
mare se ressembler à la fin aussi qu'il
y avait une atmosphère il y avait de
l'eau il ya un champ magnétique est en
fait on va atterrir dans un ancien lac
et y avait une rivière qui alimentait ce
lac là et on va attirer près du delta de
ces trials pour chercher pour voir
inscrit aurait peut-être eu de la libye
crew biologique sur barse
en plus de ça on va prendre des
échantillons de la surface de mars
on va laisser là on va essayer de
prendre des échantillons assez variés et
on aimerait ramener ses gestionnaires de
mars vers la terre avec une autre
mission comment qu'on freine c'est qu'on
a envers et une autre mission qui
admirait sur la surface des martyrs
chercher ces échantillons là
et on appelait lui aussi une petite
fusée défaut quand même de dire ça on va
atterrir une fusée sur mars pour ramener
là aussi les échantillons les ramener
vers la terre et ça c'est pas avant quoi
quelques années là c'est toucher et long
oui c'est ça donc bon premièrement faut
se rendre là ça va nous prendre environ
une année martienne pour aller chercher
les échantillons et là on commence déjà
à planifier la prochaine mission
on pense que ça sera en vais l'envoyer
vers 2026 environ et on ramènerait les
échantillons vers 2030
l'espace c'est compliqué atterrir somme
assez compliqué donc la technologie
safran juste ça prend du temps à
développer tout ça et comme l'avait dit
cette instance
quelle est l'importance de connaître la
réponse à chaque question on cherche
vraiment ce qu'on pose la question c'est
est-ce que de la vie ailleurs que sur la
terre et ça c'est important l'enfance
est une question existentielle qu'on se
pose depuis des centaines d'années est
ce qu'on est tout seul
est ce qu'il ya de la vie ailleurs dans
ce système cela est ce qu est la vie
ailleurs dans l'univers
donc si on trouve curieux de la vie sur
mars un certain moment donné pendant les
prochaines questions ça va être bon est
ce que c'est la même vie que sur la
terre d'où est ce que ça vient
commençait à se développer pourquoi ça a
changé pièces qu'on est tout seul c'est
quoi notre place dans l'univers alors
c'est des questions bon scientifique
très peu mais ça répond aussi à une
question humanitaire de savoir d'où est
ce qu'on vient c'est quoi notre place
est ce que dans votre esprit
c'est inévitable que d'ici 10 20 30 ans
il y à une station où des humains vont
pouvoir travailler un certain temps sur
mars
je pense que oui ça fait partie ça fait
partie des bus scientifique et début de
l'exploration déjà aux états unis on est
en train de se préparer à retourner vers
la lune donc je la prochaine étape ce
serait se rendre dans marty en fait
persévérance nous aident à se préparer
pour ça aussi on a une station
météorologique sur persévérance on a un
radar qui vous quittiez la surface ont
tous du robot et on au même
on a même un instrument qui peut
extraire de l'oxygène
mossialos ya des morts c'est plutôt du
dioxyde de carbone et on veut montrer
qu'on peut extraire de l'oxygène qui
nous servir est peut-être un jour un
instrument similaire à produire de
l'oxygène pour les astronautes
sara lee mais votre travail plus
précisément par rapport à ce robot low
key qu'est-ce que vous manipulez quel
est votre champ d'expertisé puis votre
tâche
exact au cours des prochains jours mais
pendant les tests à voir qu'on envoie le
robot j'étais vraiment travailler plus
sur tout ce qui était la conduite du
robot savoir comment on est orienté ou
est-ce qu'on est sur notre enfance et ma
job d'être comparé le robot total de
mars
donc demain et surtout jouait trop
content à la console en fait après
l'atterrissage et je vais faire partie
de l'équipe qui veut qui va vérifier si
tout va bien avec le robot savoir en
quelles orientations qu'on ait être ce
qu on peut se parler on peut parler vers
la terre et dans les semaines après ça
mes tâches vont être plutôt sûr je
travailler un peu sur l'hélicoptère
qu'on amène avec nous il va démontrer le
premier vol sur mer c'est moi qui
organise des opérations pour ça et je
vous parlais avant du plan complet pour
le robot à chaque jour une de mes tâches
cbd à préparer ce plan là en fait c'est
moi qu'il assemble toutes toutes les
morceaux que chaque équipe nous donne et
qui est d'envoyer sa pour le robot à
chaque jour on est bien fiers en tout
cas j'avais jette arrivé ici vos parents
et migrants farah ali b vous avez
un travail déjà extraordinaire d'être
rendus là où vous êtes
on va suivre cette mission là est toute
la suite avec ce robot quand même qui
semble extraordinaire il n'y a pas
danger en quelques secondes qu'il arrive
sur le doute si ça arrive que vous
faites pour le ramener au cdja le plein
il ya plein de petits danger c'est sûr
on a fait la meilleure offre aux
femelles c'est toujours difficile
d'atterrir sur mars et est comme ça avec
tout le monde demeure une regarder ça en
même temps donc on va toujours mieux
pour elle pour essayer de l'arracher
merci beaucoup au revoir merci